avec plus de 100000 panneaux solaires il
est capable de produire l'équivalent de
la consommation annuelle en électricité
d'un gros village oui de l'électricité
pour 1400 habitants précisément une
goutte d'eau dans nos besoins
énergétiques et pourtant ce parc
photovoltaïque est unique puisqu'il est
porté par des citoyens et c'est à
Saint-Benoît la forêt que ça se passe
selon notre question web d'ailleurs vous
êtes plus de 60 % à soutenir ce genre
d'initiative en faveur de la transition
écologique alors en quoi consiste de ce
projet près de Chinon voyez ce reportage
de Clémence
d'que 5400 panneaux solaires au cœur de
la forêt chinonaise un parc
photovoltaïque de la taille de deux
terrains de foot est en service depuis
juin dernier sa partic particularité il
a été en partie financé par des citoyens
pouvoir y contribuer en tant que citoyen
pour nous c'était important de d'y
donner une marque et une marque
spécifique de la région puisque des
projets citoyen il y en a pas tant que
ça en plus c'est un parc qui est
construit sur une décharge donc c'est ça
prend pas de terrain agricole c'est pas
de gagner de l'argent làdessus non non
non c'est vraiment de de d'aider à la
réalisation d'un projet tel que celui-là
si le parc produit près de deux fois la
consommation électrique des habitants de
Saint-Benoît la forêt ces derniers
gardent leurs abonnements au
fournisseurs d'énergie habituel
l'électricité issue du parc est injectée
au réseau général les gens peuvent
acheter une action à partir de 100 € et
investir dans un projet local qui est
vraiment porté par des citoyens et qui
va produire de l'énergie pour les
citoyens localement voilà et qui va
aussi rapporter des taxes pour la comcom
pour la commune qui vont donc permettre
d'améliorer les services aussi publics
les services proposés par par les comcom
un projet qui permet de donner une
nouvelle vie à un terrain aux
utilisations limitées et qui n'empiète
sur aucune propriété privée ou agricole
le foncier c'est un site entropisé qui
appartient donc à la à la mairie et le
le le bail est de 40 ans donc le projet
à une durée de vie de 40 ans après dans
40 ans au-delà on verra on verra la
suite grâce à ce parc 105 tonnes
d'émissions de CO2 sont évités chaque
année etlu et association espèrent en
faire un exemple de production d'énergie
propre et en circuit
court